alors que le va tout mettre dans le
compost dans la poubelle à compost est
ce que tu sais ce que tu y mets réflexes
ne sont pas encore naturel pour cette
élève de l'école louise weiss
depuis le début du mois de juin les
écoliers tri ce qu'ils restent dans leur
assiette
ça m'aidait la nature j'adore la nature
heures j'ai fait très attention ce qui
te rend à mayol pour les déchets bah ça
leur permet de faire moins de travail
l'école élémentaire est la première des
neuf établissements de la commune a
testé cette expérience une
sensibilisation qui se fait avec les
élèves les enseignants des associations
manic oise et les services municipaux
c'est en fait la plus grosse école de la
commune
elle continue elle comprend onze classes
et à la restauration scolaire il ya 245
élèves donc et un comptage a été fait et
en moyenne ya quinze kilos de déchets
par jour
ces actions comme beaucoup d'autres
d'ailleurs que l'on mène dans notre
école s'inscrivent dans le creux projet
d'école dans ce projet d'école il est
prévu un volet agenda 21
et donc nous sommes amenés en place et
avec des enfants à les sensibiliser sur
tous les enjeux écologiques les enjeux
de protection de la planète au
protection de l'environnement est
également sur le développement durable
les restes sont ensuite jetés dans des
composteurs installé dans la cour en
début de semaine un compost qui sera
utilisé pour les espaces verts de la
ville